chaos ensues in the Iowa caucuses as
Democrats failed to tally up the votes
mayor cheat Buddha judge declares
himself the winner even though no
official votes have come in at all and
he's not pulling at the top in a single
state actually Bernie Sanders is pulling
at the top not just in Iowa but also in
New Hampshire and he's running second in
Nevada in South Carolina where Joe
Biden's firewall is collapsing we will
examine how a nun accomplished communist
rose to the top of the field why party
elites are trying to steal the
nomination from him again and how the
Democratic Party fell apart then the
peerless and pioneering Rush Limbaugh
announces a diagnosis of advanced stage
lung cancer we will see what the
reaction to his announcement means for
Rush and his enemies
finally a lone Democrat turns against
impeachment and rich liberal white women
pay bigots to call them racist over
dinner all that and more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
what a night what a night I'm sorry if I
look under slept I was sitting in my
studio until 1:00 in the morning with
Senator Ted Cruz we were supposed to do
our podcasts together and we couldn't
because the Iowa caucuses did not give
us the final tally so about one o'clock
I saunter over to the hotel bar in DC
just to try to find any news there are
no results whatsoever the democratic
party completely bungled this and then
and then the best part of all mayor Pete
the cheat Budaj edge comes on stage and
without any official votes in declares
himself the winner vindicating every
single thing I've been saying about this
guy for several months we will get to
mayor Pete's fake victory speech we'll
get to what this means for the party in
2020 but first I've got to thank our
friends over at NetSuite let me tell you
something Iowa should have proven this
to you technology is not perfect okay if
you don't know your numbers then you
don't know your business but the problem
that growing businesses have that keeps
them from growing their numb from
knowing their numbers rather is these
hodgepodge of business systems that
don't talk to each other so you might
have one system for accounting another
for sales another for inventory and
another for tallying up the votes in
Iowa and just somehow they're not
talking to each other and it's a big
inefficient mess and it can take up way
too much of your time and too many
resources and that is going to hurt the
bottom line because time is money
introducing NetSuite by Oracle the
business management software that
handles every aspect of your business
in an easy-to-use cloud platform giving
you the visibility and control you need
to grow with NetSuite you save time you
save money you save unneeded headaches
up in part of many growing businesses I
really really wish that I had been able
to have all my business systems talking
to each other when we started we saved a
lot of time and a lot of money right now
NetSuite is offering you valuable
insights with a free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite dot-com / Knowles canna wles
NetSuite comm / Knowles Keo wles to
download your free guide seven key
stress
to grow your profits NetSuite comm /
Knowles I bet they wish they typed in
that URL in Iowa last night because it
was an absolute an absolute disaster
unprecedented really there have been
problems in Iowa the last few years
actually Iowa may lose its favored
position as the first in the nation
voting this was by far the worst what
happened the caucuses are already very
very complicated the caucus a caucus is
not like a primary vote when you go to
vote in a poll right you walk in you
give them your ID in some places in some
places you don't even have to do that
then you go into a polling booth you
click the either right in the candidate
you want you pull the lever right you
leave right that's not what a caucus is
in a caucus especially the Democratic
caucus which is the most complicated you
show up and you sit at tables and you
try to persuade people to vote for the
candidates you like then you move to
your own separate corners of the room so
maybe the Bernie guys go to the
northwest corner and the Biden guys go
to the the northeast corner and so on
and so forth then if one candidate
doesn't meet the threshold of voters
let's say they don't get 15 percent of
the voters then all those guys get freed
up and they've got to go to different
corners of the room or they can remain
independent and unaffiliated it is at
its best working absolutely perfectly
it's almost impossible to understand how
a caucus works then add on to that that
the software the app that was being used
to report the results at each caucus
location mysteriously broke down
whoopsie-daisy so we have no idea who
voted for whom we still have no idea now
that that would be enough to say maybe
something crooked is going on here
maybe it's incompetence maybe there is a
conspiracy at foot right now add on to
that this little fact the company that
made the app that reports who voted for
whom at the Iowa caucuses is called
shadow incorporated if you were
a Hollywood script about stealing the
Iowa caucuses and you had to pick a
company name for who stole the Iowa
caucuses and you chose shadow
incorporated Hollywood producers would
tell you now that's too on-the-nose
that's too obvious you got to be a
little more subtle than that
so you've got shadow incorporated makes
this dodgy app that doesn't work shadow
incorporated is staffed by the veterans
of Hillary Clinton's campaign what is
Hillary's nickname crooked Hillary one
of the most corrupt figures in American
politics it gets better
the company that owns shadow
Incorporated isn't even more
mysteriously named acronym that's that's
the name of it acronym it's the most
vague enigmatic mysterious name you
could think of and then here's this
little juicy tidbit at the end the
campaign's of people to judge and Joe
Biden the to establishment types
trailing in Iowa in recent weeks both
made payments to shadow incorporated
they have used she had two incorporated
the company that made the app to count
the votes as a vendor for their
campaigns they've paid the money
according to reports today really really
dodgy and then the piece de resistance
the cherry on top of the crooked sundae
mayor Pete Buda judge just declared
himself the winner last night no votes
were in no evidence that he won it all
no evidence he got a single vote all the
polls in recent days showed he wasn't
winning in Iowa and yet he just goes up
there and declares himself the winner
here's mayor Pete in his own words
[Music]
tonight an improbable hope became an
undeniable reality we have to stop right
there
what does that mean
an impossible hope became an undeniable
reality what that's those are just words
mashed together that don't mean anything
that Mayor Pete says like they have a
lot of meaning an impossible hope what
is the impossible hope is to win the
Iowa caucuses it's not an impossible
hope somebody wins the Iowa caucuses
every single year it's not impossible
someone's gonna win it then a bunch of
people are gonna lose but someone's
gonna win it that's not an impossible
hope what's the undeniable reality that
people judge one that is the most
deniable statement you could make
because we don't have any votes in yet
an undeniable reality I have been saying
this about people to judge for months
since the beginning of his campaign he
is the worst these candidates he is
slimy he is unctuous he is dishonest
he is smarmy he is sanctimonious he is
he is my least favorite candidate I
would take Bernie Sanders over Pete
bootie judge I would take Elizabeth
Warren over Pete Buddha judge I would
take Who Leon Castro and abortion rights
for men over Pete who to judge because
the guy is just so dishonest he made he
made a really big miscalculation last
night trying to pretend with no evidence
that he won Iowa he goes on to explain
how he is about to stroll into New
Hampshire victorious so we don't know
all the results but we know by the time
it's all said and done Iowa you have
shocked the nation
[Applause]
by all indications we are going on to
New Hampshire victorious by all
indications we are going into New
Hampshire victorious that isn't true by
no indications is he going into New
Hampshire victorious not one not one
vote this was a major miscalculation
some people are saying it was
politically brilliant they're saying
it's politically brilliant cuz no one's
really paying that close attention to
the Iowa caucuses and the only headline
they're gonna see is Buddha judge is the
winner Buddha judge says he's the winner
and so it's going to give him the
illusion of winning even though very
likely he came in what third or fourth
place who know I mean who knows we don't
have the numbers but there's there's no
evidence that he came in first they're
saying look he's just gonna fake it till
he makes it and that's gonna send him
into New Hampshire looking good it's a
mistake it's a big mistake because
people actually are paying attention to
the Democratic Iowa caucuses namely the
primary voters and by the way primary
voters pay a lot more attention to
politics than general election voters
your general election voters are you
kind of normal people it's about half
the country who shows up to general
elections and they pay a little bit of
attention and so maybe you could pull
one over on them primary voters actually
care they care a lot more they're more
tuned into to the party politics
especially in this field where there's
so many different candidates especially
in Iowa especially New Hampshire Nevada
South Carolina these early states that
are going to really matter and probably
decide who gets the nomination Pete
Budaj went into Iowa according to the in
perceptive right not according to me
I've always known that guy's a snake but
according to the people who were not
perceiving it he was hopeful he was
young he was earnest he was a guy you
could trust he's just telling it like it
is right happy old mayor Pete American
as apple pie
he's leaving Iowa looking like a loser
and a liar and a crook it's the only way
to describe it if
really one then you can wait for the
votes to be counted if you really won
right if your which is most likely
Bernie Sanders judging by all of the
polls going into this thing you can wait
for the voice of the voters to be heard
if you are really earnest and honest and
up-and-coming and hopeful and we're
gonna turn a new page in America and
unite everybody then you don't need to
steal a state you don't need to pretend
now even his victory speech
he's calling attention to the fact that
he's apparently got some financial
relationship with the app company that
mysteriously broke that was supposed to
count the votes it just doesn't look
good and Budaj edges to undefined a
candidate to to risk that you know one
of one of trumps big advantages in 2016
is everybody knew who he was he had
basically a hundred percent name
recognition everyone watched him on
network television for ten years
everybody watched him on the tabloids
and in real estate and in pop culture
for thirty years before that nobody
knows mayor Pete he's the mayor of a
small town so every every new data point
that defines him is going to really
really matter and he's now allowing
himself to be defined as a slippery guy
unctuous oily maybe crooked
maybe he's got a weird financial
relationship with the app maybe he's
trying to cheat the voters out of their
nominee maybe they're trying to cheat
Bernie Sanders which is what happened in
2016 by all indications we're going to
New Hampshire victorious there's no
indication because we don't know what
happened in Iowa to sum it up CNN to
their credit summed up better than any
other Network any other outlet what the
Iowa caucuses looked like last night
when one on one of the precinct captains
one of the guys who's got to call a
hotline now to report the votes is on
the phone with CNN's Wolf Blitzer and
these trying to handle both of these at
the same time and it all falls apart
we'll get to that in a second first I've
got to thank our friends over at liquid
Ivy you know I love liquid Ivy Energy
Drink
SuperDuper sugary drinks pounding coffee
all day long that can lead to a crash
after the initial spike you don't want
that if you want to have some more
energy it's really nice to
hydrate yourself and liquid IV as a
hydration multiplier you know how much I
love it liquid IV is energy multiplier
tastes great
tastes just like their lemon-lime flavor
that one's my favorite you mix it in the
water and you drink it the energy
multiplier gives you a sustained energy
boost with no crash premium matcha and
green energy blend tastes delicious and
provides a lasting energy boost
throughout the day so you're not gonna
crash right the fatigue fighting boost
that you would get from a couple of cups
of coffee you can get that without the
crash it's really really good you know I
love liquid IV because it's it's great
if you want to hydrate and you're an
athlete if you're not an athlete like me
maybe you just go out to the cigar bar
and have a couple too many coca-cola's
maybe it's good to have the liquid IV
there as well
I just love it I haven't slept in
probably two weeks while I've been in
Washington DC liquid IV can give you
that that sustained energy without the
crash get 25% off when you go to liquid
IV dot-com and use code Knowles at
checkout ko wles you know that I use
liquid IV you know that I rely on it you
should check it out to 25% off anything
you order on liquid IVs website liquid
IV dot-com enter promo code Knowles
canna wles to save 25% get better
hydration and energy liquid IV com promo
code Knowles don't wait
start fueling your adventures today
you're gonna need that liquid IV energy
boost when we're waiting up for the next
three weeks to get the results from the
Iowa caucuses so just to give you a
sense if you weren't waiting up all
night CNN has one of the precinct
captains on the phone the precinct
captain is also on the phone with the
hotline that had to spring up to try to
report the vote tally after this weird
app went down take a listen to the chaos
they tried I think promote an app to
report the results the app by all
accounts just like doesn't work so we've
been recommended to call into the
hotline and the hotline has not been
responsive
as to what's going on no I have not no
I'm just waiting on hold and doing my
best to report the results remotely what
are you hearing I know you're listening
to a conversation from the Iowa
Democratic Party this is a real
coincidence wolf I just got off hold
just so I've got to get off the phone to
report the results all right now go
ahead and report it what can we listen
in as you report them so on yep okay hi
hello they hung up on me okay I've got
to get back on hold so frustrating
indeed she hung up hung up he was
waiting on the phone for an hour to try
to report these results and they hung up
and we got to hear it on national
television this is the most honest and
news-breaking broadcast I've ever seen
on CNN so kudos to them this is this is
a big deal for Iowa because Iowa is the
first in the nation state to start start
choosing these presidential candidates
it's hard to imagine that they keep that
after this year this was just such a
bungle and it very well might be
incompetence however because the
Democratic Party has this long record of
corruption the Democratic Party has this
long record of ignoring the will of
their own voters and having party elites
choose the nominee because the
Democratic Party has a very recent
history of rigging the election in favor
of Hillary Clinton instead of Bernie
Sanders this thing looks crooked whether
it is or not Bernie Sanders was going
into Iowa at the top of the heap in many
ways that the Democratic Party has been
refashioned
in the mold of Bernie Sanders and the
voters have been pulling for him in many
of these early states he's got a huge
lead in New Hampshire and the fact that
the tally went down that nobody knows
what's going on the fact
that there is or some reports of
financial relationships between Biden
and Budaj edge and the app company it
just stinks to high heaven and if you
thought that the Bernie bros were
incensed before and they sensed
corruption before just wait until they
move on to New Hampshire Joe Biden
meanwhile is completely falling apart
even if even if the Iowa vote doesn't
end his candidacy and it there's a lot
of evidence that the Biden team thought
that they were gonna do very poorly in
Iowa they're trying to tamp down
expectations all day in New Hampshire
they might fall apart Joe Biden just did
an interview with Savannah Guthrie on
NBC and even NBC even the mainstream
media even Savannah Guthrie pushed Joe
Biden to answer any questions about his
son hunter and the clearly corrupt
relationship between hunter in the
Ukraine and possibly the corrupt
relationship between Joe Biden in
Ukraine Joe Biden not only refuses to
answer he snaps at the host has it
occurred to you that there's a certain
irony here that here the president is
accused of and is acknowledged wanting
to get information about your son Hunter
and his dealings with Ukraine and this
process of impeachment has ensured that
everyone knows about hunters dealings
with Ukraine except they say that's a
bad image my son said that do you think
it was wrong for him to take that
position knowing that it was really
because company wanted access to you
well that's not true you're saying
things you do not know what you're
talking about
no one said that who said that it's just
one of those things where people think
well that seems kind of sleazy why would
he have that job if not for his who his
father was
he's a very bright guy I guess the
question I'm kind of asking is was it
right as a parent yeah
yeah well he said he regretted having
done it speech himself it's a girl thing
you're gonna predict a win tomorrow
night
I don't predict wins because I'm
superstitious but I predict with her
very well you don't know what you're
talking about you don't know you don't
know that there was a crooked
relationship between hunter and Ukraine
yes we do yes we do
hunter Biden is a degenerate who got
kicked out of the Navy for doing drugs
who has destroyed his personal life who
gets in bar fights who drunk drives
everywhere who has basically no
professional credential and he was being
paid a million dollars a year to sit on
the board of a Ukrainian energy company
while his daddy was the vice president
of the United States and the point man
on Ukraine hunter Biden was being paid
about three times or more than three
times what board members of ExxonMobil
get paid to sit on the board of this
crooked company the company's so crooked
that just before hunter Biden was
invited to join the board the government
of the United Kingdom froze their assets
because they suspected such corruption
there are many reasons to ask this
question Joe Biden needs to give an
answer he would do much better to just
admit that it was wrong and move on you
know back when the media were backing
Joe Biden back when the establishment
press was behind his candidacy then it
made sense for Joe Biden to ignore these
questions and to obfuscate and to try to
distract people but now the media have
turned on him the media have turned on
him because he's an extraordinarily weak
candidate whose eyeballs explode on
debate stages and whose teeth fall out
of his mouth and who starts talking
about corn pop and kids rubbing his legs
and who can't finish an English sentence
I hate to put it that bluntly but that's
where it is he's simply past his sell-by
date and so the media have turned on him
the party elites have turned on him I
was speaking with senator Ted Cruz on
our ship verdict the other night and he
said that one of his biggest takeaways
from the impeachment trial was how the
Democratic Party elites had given up on
Joe Biden that's why the House Democrats
threw him under the bus during
impeachment is because they just felt
Biden did
have it anymore so everybody's turned on
him they don't think he's got what it
takes to win now he's got to get
aggressive now he's got to confront
these problems head-on he's not gonna
have a media apparatus that's carrying
water for him anymore the current
strategy for the Biden campaign is to
lose slowly it's just to lose as slowly
as you can and then hope that somehow
you haven't lost enough that you lose
the nomination it's kind of the Romney's
strategy in 2012 it's it's just weak
sauce and it's not gonna last very long
especially when you've got a highly
motivated base for Bernie Sanders
they're still doing everything they can
to steal this from Bernie not just Mayer
cheat that's just old Joe Biden not just
the Democratic establishment but even
the press there was a poll that came out
just before the Iowa caucuses Des Moines
Register poll this was the Des Moines
Register final poll before the Iowa
caucuses and they wouldn't release it
why wouldn't they release the numbers we
finally got him the numbers finally
leaked the numbers were Joe Biden down
all the way at 13%
mayorchik Budaj 16% Elizabeth Warren 18%
and Bernie Sanders in the lead at 22%
they didn't like that they didn't like
that poll going into the Iowa caucuses
this poll was conducted with CNN and
Seltzer and company seltzer and company
was the pollster in charge here
according to 538 according to really top
pollsters they had an a-plus rating okay
this was no minor polling company now
the excuse was that some respondent to
the poll didn't see one of the names and
so better to just get rid of the poll
again after all these coincidences it's
really hard to believe that and even if
I can believe that because I do think
that the Democratic Party leadership is
incompetent it's gonna be very hard for
the supporters of Bernie Sanders to
believe that whoops they made a mistake
that hurt Bernie whoops they made
another mistake that hurt Bernie
whoopsi-daisy whoopsi-daisy OE and all
of 2016 that was a big mistake that hurt
Bernie they're just not going to believe
it and if they keep this up
they don't give Bernie his do you're
going to see a fight at the Democratic
National Convention the likes of which
we haven't seen probably since the 1960s
we've got so much more to get to
including the the shifting gears from
the Democrats over to the right-wing
really really sad news from the peerless
rush limbaugh we will get to that in a
second we will get to why the left just
loves humanity and hates humans and we
will get to one little bit of hope from
a Senate Democrat but first gotta thank
our friends over at zip recruiter cafe
alturas co o Dillon Miska wits
experienced how challenging hiring can
be after unsuccessfully searching for a
director of coffee for his organic
coffee company over the past two weeks I
could have probably taken the job of
director of coffee but Dillon didn't
call me
then Dillon switch to zip recruiter and
saw an immediate difference you can too
by signing up for free at the zip
recruiter dot-com slash Knowles canna
wles
zip recruiter does not depend on
candidates finding you that's what a lot
of other hiring apps and websites do
it's like throwing spaghetti at the wall
that's not zip recruiter the zip
recruiter finds the candidates for you
it's technology identifies people with
the right experience and invites them to
apply to your job you just get qualified
candidates faster we've tried to hire
people in LA it can be very very
difficult
zip recruiter makes it so much easier
they go out and do the work for you
zip recruiter is simply the smartest way
to hire cy zip recruiter is effective
for businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free at our web address
zip recruiter comm slash Knolls Canada
wles that is a zip recruiter comm slash
Knolls
moving on from chaos in Iowa to really
really sad news from the golden aib
microphone and the peerless rush
limbaugh who has talent on loan from god
and does this job with half his brain
tied behind his back rush limbaugh
announced yesterday on his show that he
has been diagnosed with
advanced lung cancer this news was so
big that you know over the past two
weeks have we've been working all kind
of crazy hours and I've been up in the
middle of the night recording the show
with senator Cruz and working and doing
this show during the day and so I try to
get any bit of sleep I can I was getting
an hour of sleep yes bad just laid down
and sweet little ELISA wakes me up
because this news was so shocking and
the news was the great Rush Limbaugh has
this very very serious illness it's
everybody's praying for rush rush is
praying for rush and we'll get to
actually the significance of that in a
second I want to get to the reaction
first CNN tweets out CNN breaking news
tweets a quote Rush Limbaugh the most
prominent political radio host in the
u.s. says he's been diagnosed with an
advanced stage of lung cancer here are
just a handful of replies and these are
not the worst replies these are not a
few fringy replies this is indicative of
most of the replies to that tweet from
random Twitter accounts quote who knew
racism was a carcinogen hell has his
seat warmed up Oh karma is good love
this he had it coming I'd tell him
thoughts and prayers but Rush has been
rendered deaf by years of opiate abuse
rotting from the inside as many have
suspected wasn't even just random
accounts that were spewing this bile at
Rush Risa acelin a CNN contributor
sometimes CNN contributor tweeted out
ask yourself this simple question is the
world a better place or a worse place
with Rush Limbaugh in it tarik nasheed
is another blue checkmark leftist on
Twitter tweet it at a Jif of a guy
dancing in celebration because Rush
Limbaugh was diagnosed with cancer not
one of these people has ever listened to
Russia's show
no one they've listened to one or two
minutes that were taken out of context
and posted on left-wing hate sites like
Media Matters but they've never listened
to the show not a single one of them
even what they're saying is is
incoherent who knew racism was a
carcinogen when his Rush Limbaugh
ever said anything racist actually the
only on the Rush Limbaugh program the
only other guy that anybody knows of is
Bo standardly his producer who's black
not a lot of evidence that he's a racist
Heil has his seat warmed up this from
people who very likely don't believe in
heaven or hell
Oh karma is good love this he had it
coming he had it Kawhi did he have it
coming because he said hateful things
according to you well did he say
anything as hateful as that he had it
coming
I'd tell him thoughts and prayers but
Rush has been rendered deaf by years of
opiate abuse so making fun of a guy for
being deaf he actually does have hearing
difficulty as a cochlear implant and
because he did he did suffer from opiate
abuse he was addicted to opiates and yet
these are people who would accuse you of
ableism if you ever made a comment about
somebody who had a disability like Rush
who would accuse you of being a monster
if you mocked somebody for struggling
with drug addiction and yet they do both
they do both to rush rotting from the
inside as many have suspected who's
really rotting from the inside probably
the people who were who were sending out
those those tweets none of them has ever
listened to Rush that's why they can
they can say these things but why does
the left hate Rush they hate him in
particular we will examine why and we'll
examine a really hopeful note from Rush
in his masterful statement on the
diagnosis first it feels like we're
halfway through 2020 Italy it feels sort
of like we're 3/4 of the way through
2020 but the truth is we have not even
gotten started the election is just
heating up and because we know that you
need to stay up to date we're giving you
20% off all new memberships that is 20%
off all new memberships when using promo
code DW 2020 members get our articles
add free access to all of our live
broadcasts in show library the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
select bonus content access to the
mailbag and now our new all-access tier
gets you into live online Q&A
discussions like the one that we are
hosting tonight after backstage
state-of-the-union we will be streaming
at 8:30 p.m. Eastern 5:30 Pacific we
will bring you president from speech
live with our analysis and answer all of
your questions in an exclusive online
Q&A over a Dale
why calm slash discussions again that's
promo code DW 20 24 20 percent off join
today and stay informed on all things
2020 head on over to daily wire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
why does the left hate rush limbaugh so
much there's a game called cards against
humanity' it's a very stupid game that
Millennials pretend is kind of funny but
it's not it's not even really a game
it's just they're sort of grotesque
things written on cards which are kind
of funny or amusing the first one or two
times that you read them but then
they're not really funny afterward
because we've all heard the jokes and
they're kind of just non sequiturs so
anyway one of the grotesquerie Zinn on
the cards is is Rush Limbaugh's soft
profanity body and it's kind of like mad
libs but for Millennials who don't know
how to play poker and rush gets singled
out even in that rush gets singled out
all the time they don't really go after
the other radio guys or the other
podcasters it's just Rush and that's
because Rush is the king the left hates
Rush because he is effective he invented
the whole genre of talk radio he's so
good at it he was the first conservative
to beat the mainstream media he did it
by inventing a new medium he did it by
being funny he's just very entertaining
and he did it by telling the truth he is
by far the most insightful political
analyst on radio I'm friends with some
of the other ones him they're great too
but Russia's number one there is no
number two and they hated him for it
they hated him for getting around the
mainstream media they hated him for
being effective if you weren't effective
they wouldn't waste their time on him
now lots of people are wishing ill on
Rush on the left-right a little bit of
these random Twitter people but even
some prominent leftists many
conservatives are insisting that he'll
beat this they're saying you'll beat
this Rush don't you worry you'll recover
you'll be back in shape in no time
I hope so I don't know that I'm not sure
that he'll beat it forever I mean
everybody dies eventually we're praying
for him we
that he'll beat it but no one here gets
out alive I don't think the thing to
focus on is is even whether rush can
prolong his career
two years five years or 10 years I think
the thing to focus on is that rush is
already accomplished in his life more
than virtually anybody
he's other than a handful of people
throughout history he's accomplished a
lot more and the thing to focus on is
what he talked about in his statement
announcing this rush fortunately has a
long view of life not merely confined to
the 70 or 80 years that we get well
we're here but the longer view the
Eternity view he said he doesn't talk
about it much but he did mention it in
his announcement he mentioned his
relationship with God I've had so much
support from family and friends during
this that it's it's just it's it's been
tremendous I told the staff today that I
have a deeply personal relationship with
God that I do not proselytize about but
I do and I have been working that
relationship tremendously which I do
regularly anyway but I've been focused
on it intensely for the past couple of
weeks
that's a beautiful statement life is a
preparation for death
rush seems to take that seriously people
who are religious I can speak as a
Catholic we take that seriously life is
a preparation for death how long do you
get on earth if you're lucky 70 80 years
by the by the scale of eternity that's
nothing that's the blink of an eye
obviously we should pray for rush
I hope he's around for another twenty or
thirty years the guy is so great I just
love listening to him we don't need to
be quite as worried about rush we should
be far more worried about the people
wishing ill upon him I don't mean that
in some kind of cliche way or
sentimental Eeyore though these people
have problems
imagine how twist it you've got to be
inside how tense your guts
have to be how perverse your soul has to
be to say the kind of things that Rize a
slant or tarik Nasheed or any of those
Twitter accounts said about another
human being
wishing death upon somebody wishing
suffering celebrating somebody's cancer
diagnosis you got to be so messed up
inside your life has got to be a misery
and if you take the long view of life
then it doesn't look like it's going to
get any better once we've shuffled off
this mortal coil doesn't rush could use
our prayers the people cheering on
Russia's illness could use our prayers
more Russia actually in the same
broadcast talked about the other side of
this not just the sorrow or the grief or
the anger or the resentment he talked
about joy we mentioned it on his show he
mentioned an article that just came out
by left-wing reporter Ryan Lizza and the
cancer diagnosis the reaction to his
cancer diagnosis on the left really
drives this point home the article by
Ryan lizards in Politico said the
unexpected joy at a trump rally in Iowa
on the cusp of beating two articles of
impeachment the president's fans were in
a celebratory mood meanwhile somewhere
there was a Democratic race taking place
I had not been to a trump rally since
the 2016 campaign and the first thing I
noticed Thursday night when Donald Trump
and Mike Pence spoke at Drake University
in Des Moines was how much more joyous
the event was for his supporters than
what I remember from four years ago in
2016 perhaps because Republicans were
out of power and Trump was running
purely against the system
his crowds often had an undertone of
anger that bordered on menacing but with
Trump in power presiding over peace and
prosperity on the cusp of beating two
articles of impeachment and dominating
the news when it should be the
Democratic candidates moment to shine
his fans seemed in a celebratory mood
she is surprised by the joy at the Trump
rally now he says that the Trump rallies
are totally different now than they were
in 2016 I don't think they are I think
maybe Ryan Lizza and some leftists are
looking at it differently now then in
2016 2016 it was menacing terrifying
horrifying oh no
a Republican might be elected president
right it's terrible cuz we were told in
2016 that if Trump got elected president
the sky would fall I mean literally the
sky would fall because global warming
would kill us all
we would have an economic collapse we'd
start World War 3 we'd be a war with
North Korea we'd have Russia would take
over our country I mean all this kind of
craziness and then Trump got elected and
what three four years later everything's
great everything's great it's awesome
the the economy is good we got peace
abroad they told us that Trump had
started World War three well I guess we
won World War three when we took out the
top terrorists in the world the leader
of Isis the top Iranian terrorist
another leader of Isis just this past
week I mean it's just things are good
and so Ryan listen now can look at the
Trump rally without this hysterical fear
that the left was ginning up in 2016 and
he says I'll look those guys are happy
those guys are joyful even huh I haven't
seen that before because the left
doesn't really seem to have a lot of joy
they seem to be pretty bitter pretty
angry pretty crooked in Iowa Joy's an
important thing in politics CS Lewis
defined joy is not not a feeling or an
emotion like happiness happiness is
fleeting right now gonna be happy
forever but joy is something greater and
deeper and more enduring is sort of like
an unanswered question the pursuit of
that would be would be similar to joy
and I think conservatives just tend to
have that in politics a lot more part of
that is because we don't expect politics
to solve all of our problems we actually
know the politics won't solve all of our
problems we don't think that you can
perfect human nature we recognize humans
are all broken and flawed and that's
just the way it is and we're gonna we're
gonna try to fit our politics to reality
rather than try to perfect human nature
because those utopian schemes to perfect
human nature have led to some of the
worst atrocities in history is a feeling
of gratitude Hey look we were on the
brink we almost had President Hillary Oh
heaven forfend and now we don't and we
got this kind of funny guy in the Oval
Office and he tweets weird stuff
sometimes and that's kind of
entertaining and also the economy is
great and everything seems
be fine that's when you approach
politics from gratitude that's when you
approach politics from levity you know
Chesterton said that the angels can fly
because they can take themselves lightly
the left can't take itself lightly the
left can't even turn down the partisan
ranker for five seconds when a guy that
they don't like listening to gets
diagnosed with cancer they have to
celebrate that for what for what does
that does that make you a better person
does that make you flourish more does
that make you thrive does that make you
happy
I don't think so I don't think so and
that the joy that that Ryan Lizza and
some left wingers are seeing at Trump
rallies maybe that's an evidence that
something has gone wrong in their own
worldview maybe there's something
lacking in their own political ideology
maybe rather than looking down on those
people at Trump rallies like the CNN
anchors the other day who laughed at the
mocked them those idiots those rubes
they can't spell they can't read maps
rather than than that maybe they ought
to try to learn a thing or two from the
guys at the Trump rallies because the
guys at the Trump rallies on the one
hand seem to know how to win elections a
little bit better than the left wingers
and they seem to know how to live life a
little more joyfully more gratifyingly
speaking of the left learning from the
right there's a glimmer of hope from
Senate Democrats just one actually
Senate Democrat joe Manchin joe Manchin
West Virginia gobby's he comes from a
conservative constituency Joe Manson is
is considering voting against the
impeachment and removal of President
Trump he would be the lone Democrat to
do it here's why he said quote never
before in the history of our republic
has there been a purely partisan
impeachment vote of a president totally
true
removing this president at this time
would not only further divide our deeply
divided nation but also further poison
are already toxic political atmosphere
I see no path to the 67 votes that would
be required to remove President Trump
however I do believe a bipartisan
majority of this body would vote to
censure President Trump in other words
pass a resolution saying he's a no-good
bad boy but not remove him from office
a censure he says would allow this body
to unite across party lines
joe manchin doesn't want to vote to
remove the president cuz he's afraid
it's going to cost him his re-election
in West Virginia he is right though this
is the first purely partisan impeachment
we've ever had
purely partisan impeachments are a very
bad idea it's not designed to work that
way you're the president is not supposed
to be removed just because another party
won another branch of government it's
supposed to be bipartisan that's why I
require 67 votes in the Senate to do it
that's why we've never had a partisan
impeachment before I agree with mention
that if Nancy Pelosi instead of pushing
for impeachment had pushed for censure
just to say that Trump is a no-good guy
they could have gotten some Republican
votes definitely in the house maybe in
the Senate - they're not going to do
that though they're gonna vote now on
whether to acquit the President or
whether to remove him from office and
joe Manchin has to make a choice if he
had the political courage to vote
against the removal of the president and
maybe if he convinced one or two of his
Senate colleagues for more conservative
states Kyrsten Sinema or maybe Doug
Jones Democrats and conservative states
you might have a chance of kind of
bridging that divide and turning down
the partisan ranker it's probably
unlikely but joe Manchin could do a lot
so he should take his own advice and and
try to do it before we go I have to get
to this this story is just too good not
to get to there are groups of white
women white liberal women who are paying
$2,500 to confront their own racism and
privilege by inviting two activists
Regina Jackson and Saira rouse I'm
around particular has expressed absolute
contempt for white people on Twitter
they're inviting these two activists to
come over to these dinner parties called
race to dinner and yell at them for
being racist and bigoted $2500 I would
do it for 2,000 if these women want to
invite me over to their homes for me to
call them bigots I would gladly do that
and I would charge I would charge
significantly less than Jackson and Rao
I hope they I hope they do that
obviously this is insane
this is a silly thing I mean it's talked
about the height of privilege to if
you're if the whole point of this dinner
is so that you can confront your
privilege then gathering all your like
wealthy white women friends and paying a
ton of money to basically be entertained
to have a show put on at dinner is
probably not the best way to get rid of
your privilege but beyond just making
fun of these women I want to point out
that it expresses a natural urge a
natural long it is a religious longing
actually because these women are racist
in some way in some way I'm using racist
in the way that it's used colloquially
today which is bad racist has become a
synonym for bad or evil or wicked that's
why people will call Rush Limbaugh
racist I don't think he's ever made a
racially bigoted comment in his life but
what they're really saying is you're bad
you're immoral I don't like you or they
do it all the time to conservatives who
have who have no evidence whatsoever of
any kind of racial hatred but they'll
say you're racist as a synonym for bad
and these women are bad because no one's
good but God because we all recognize
that we sin and all fall short of the
glory of God all the time right that's
it what they're acknowledging with these
dinners is original sin and they're
trying to gussy it up and make it seem
like it's some novel concept that
progressives discovered no we've always
known about original sin we've always
known the human nature is broken
actually that's the insight that
conservatives have that liberals just
can't seem to grasp or not grasp fully
you know in traditional Catholic
practices what you would do is instead
of paying a couple of random huckster
activists to come over to your home for
almost 3 grand and yell at you you would
show up to church and strike your
breasts and say Mia culpa mea culpa mea
Maxima culpa my fault my fault my most
grievous fault you would go to
confession you if you were in The Da
Vinci Code you'd smack yourself on the
back with the with the discipline right
you recognize that you have sinned and
you need to do some penance for that sin
this is true across all religions
including the religion of liberalism
including the religion of leftism
everybody's got to serve somebody ok the
the the lie that people's that
secularism or liberalism is somehow your
ear religious or not religious it's just
just not
it's just simply a different religion
and so on on Rush Limbaugh's point about
joy
Ryan Liz's point about joy right on how
we confront questions of life and death
and grief and sadness the questions of
how we organize ourselves and questions
of running the damned Iowa caucus you
you're going to have a worldview the
question is what worldview are you going
to have are you gonna have one of
transparency of dealing with reality of
taking the long view of recognizing your
own faults and taking responsibility for
them or are you going to blame it on
somebody else are you gonna force your
problems on somebody else are you going
to allow yourself to rot from the inside
though those are the questions that's
what's being debated right now and we're
using political language to do it but
really as Cardinal Manning said at
bottom all human conflict is theological
they're debating that out and if those
debates go as well as the Iowa caucuses
I don't think that they're gonna come to
any saving conclusions anytime soon but
how are we gonna hope let's see I'll be
back tonight on verdict with Ted Cruz
the the number one podcast for a full
week in the United States and I'll be
back here on my show tomorrow
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Jessa alvera
production assistants McKenna Waters and
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there